one of the hallmarks of the good
con-artist is that it never feels like
they're taking advantage of you
they are never taking anything from you
you give it to them willingly so they
actually the term confidence artist came
out of a man in the 1800's in New York
City who would walk around on the
streets of Manhattan dressed as a very
dapper gentleman and he'd approach other
like wise dapper gentleman and say have
you the confidence in me to lend me your
watch until tomorrow I mean what a
strange request right and so much is low
it's such a loaded question you know
what kind of a person are you what kind
of a world in society do we live in are
you abiding by the gentleman's code of
conduct you know are you going to trust
me are you going to give me your
confidence well people would give him
their watches and he obviously had no
intention of ever giving them back by
the time that he was finally caught he
had lots of watches to his name and gave
birth to the name confidence man you
give them your confidence they don't
take it you give them money they never
take it from you I mean think about
someone like Bernie Madoff people had to
beg to invest with him he would say no
he would turn them away sometimes people
waited four years before he finally
accepted their money and he did it you
know as if as if he were doing them a
huge favor okay fine you know be I'll
take your money and they were so
grateful
please take more Bernie take war because
he was doing them such a huge favor one
of the hallmarks of the confidence
artist is something called
Machiavellianism it has to do with
manipulating people for your own ends
getting them to do what you want them to
do but without their knowledge so that
they don't realize they're being
manipulated so that they think that
everything they're doing is of their own
volition people hate feeling manipulated
the moment you think you're being
manipulated you drop out you say hey no
one tells me what to do who are you to
manipulate me
and so the con doesn't work so the trick
is how do I you know give you the germ
of the idea so that you think it's your
idea how do I set up a situation so that
it's your proposal not my proposal so
that you're the one who's in charge you
would be shocked if anyone told you
otherwise in fact oftentimes when people
say hey do you realize that this might
be a con you'll laugh and you say
absolutely not
are you insane this is totally
legitimate besides it was my idea
we are fully capable of understanding
that if something is too good to be true
it is if it's happening to someone else
but when it's happening to us we can't
be objective because nothing is too good
for us we deserve it so you know you
might look at someone else and say what
were your stock market returns last year
that's a little bit crazy are you sure
the sky's legit when it's happening to
you you say oh I know how to pick them I
invested my money with the right guy
look at those returns see he knows what
he's doing and if someone tells you
aren't those a bit too good you say what
are you jealous that you didn't invest
with him you probably are wishing you
were in my shoes right now we don't
listen to reason because we deserve it
we're exceptional so we deserve
exceptional things it's not too good to
be true it's just good and when things
are going well we don't ask questions we
only ask questions when they're not
going so well